le 20e salon du prêt à porter féminin
ouvert ses portes hier à paris la mode
cette fois ci est bien c'est une mode
raccourci plutôt sage mais très variés
seulement tandis que les acheteurs palpe
les tweeds et les polices comme la
situation économique n'est pas fameuse
fameuse les mannequins défilent sur fond
de crise un reportage d'isabelle bechter
le prêt-à-porter féminin français est
toujours très créatif mais les 88000
salariés qui en vivent il ya 84 % de
femmes ne sont pas à l'abri de la crise
l'époque triomphante est révolu où la
france avait le monopole des idées de la
qualité de la diffusion depuis dix ans
les anglais les allemands les italiens
et les américains ont si bien pris le
train du prêt-à-porter en marche que
nous en exportons maintenant mois que
nos voisins allemands
même si l'industrie française du
prêt-à-porter a augmenté son chiffre
d'affaires de 11 % l'année dernière
il ne faut pas que l'arbre cache la
forêt la taille des entreprises
françaises est beaucoup trop réduite
pour soutenir la compétition
internationale les explications de
monsieur jacques gronde dont la firme
est leader européen de la perméable
féminin ça il faut que le prêt-à-porter
français
acquiert l'échelle mondiale aussi bien
par ses moyens de production en étendant
son implantation moyens de production
dans le monde entier de façon à pouvoir
bénéficier de coûts de production
inférieurs à ce qu'ils sont en france et
d'autre part le étendre nos moyens de
prospection et de vente n'ont également
dans le monde entrer dans tous les pays
par un effort accru d'investissement
humain et d'investissements commerciaux
tout l'offir ont besoin d'avoir des
antennes solide des filiales des
succursales dans l'univers pays de façon
à être vraiment implantées sur place est
à vivre avec les gens à connaître leurs
problèmes et à parler leur langue les
français sans
mais pour cela que nos voisins allemands
par exemple je ne sais pas s'ils sont
nous sommes moins doués disons que nous
avons un repère chronologique
je pense que les français sont des gens
très doués peut-être trop parfois et que
ça les mène peut-être parfois faire
moins d'efforts ne maintenant n'ont pas
le choix je pense que ces efforts seront
fait parce que c'est une question de
survie pour notre bouche capitalisation
et concentration semble donc inéluctable
pour faire face aux besoins en
investissements en france et à
l'étranger
c'est à dire d'une part l'informatique
les sillages plus sophistiqués dans les
usines françaises et d'autre part de
solides réseaux commerciaux dans les
pays d'exportation
mais c'est sur l'emploi que pèse
l'incertitude majeure car pour garder
des prix de revient compétitif il va
falloir de plus en plus sous traités
avec des pays à main d'oeuvre bon marché